哈囉大家好
歡迎來到周慕姿放心說
我是周慕姿心理師
今天邀請的大來賓是我
一直很想跟他對談的
連俞涵
哈囉大家好
我是連俞涵
我不知道大家有沒有感覺到
今天我在介紹大來賓的時候
通常我遇到我很喜歡的人
我都會非常的興奮聲音非常的大
但是你們有沒有發現我聲音有
小小新興的在壓的比較平靜
因為就是在我的心目中
其實是有一種玻璃文青感
然後我就覺得在他旁邊我應該要溫柔一點
所以我今天遇到你我是真的很開心
但剛跟你對談的時候
我發現跟我的想像還是有一點落差
就是見到真人的時候
藍牙連線傳遞的比較快速會得到更多資訊
沒錯沒錯沒錯
所以我想我應該也是不用這麼小心
但是我是真的很開心
今天可以訪問到你
因為今天有機會可以訪問到俞涵
平常沒什麼機會
要不就有新戲
要不就有新書
今天就是新書啦
沒錯
今天我們宇涵幫我們就是帶來的
他的這一本新書
就是《刺尾抱月亮》
來大家看一下
我覺得這本書很讚的部分是討論到
很多關於我們怎麼面對自己的脆弱
還有孤獨對我們的意義
以及我們怎麼跟世界重新連結跟和解
所以我想說俞涵
雖然說因為我們中後段
一定不會有時間
也不會有人想到要來介紹書
最後都是我在介紹
所以一開始你先稍微分享一下
就是怎麼會想寫這本書
那想跟大家帶來的是什麼
我覺得好像是每一個時代
大家關注的東西不太一樣
到近期我開始慢慢覺得就是
以前我們可能會比較避免談
負面的經驗啊
或是覺得有一些脆弱要隱藏起來
要假裝自己沒事
然後要有一種好的狀態
一直拿給大家看
因為我們如果出來工作或是什麼
可是我覺得越活就會越覺得
因為人並不是極其
所以我們的感受不應該被忽略
尤其是你在這個世界上
有受傷的感受
或是被傷害的感受
我覺得應該要拿出來討論
就是不要隱匿某一部分的感受
因為這樣壓抑太久的話
你其實會搞不清楚
自己到底被什麼東西困擾
所以我覺得他是可以拿出來討論的
也許你有這個困擾我也有這個困擾
大家討論以後會有新的想法出現
但如果我們都不去討論跟處理
他就會一直被堆積在那邊
久了他會混在一起看不出來那是什麼
所以我才會想要寫這本三文隨筆
就是希望大家可以
看見自己的陰影
也擁抱自己的陰影
如果你內心
因為某一些受傷的時刻
你冒出一點小小想要保護自己的刺
也沒有關係
就是你每個階段
你可以選擇自己處理的方式
然後我透過這些書寫
重新回去看這些小小的陰影
然後重新用現在的我
可以去療癒我自己的方式把它寫下來
我在看你這本書的時候
我覺得真的是很療癒
而且有一個
我其實不停的感受到兩個字
就是很真實
我在聽你講
剛剛你的分享的時候
我就覺得我好像更理解
因為大家可能就是
因為我們現在常常在講陰影
那陰影簡單的說
就是我們沒有辦法接受的
任何部分自己的任何部分
什麼東西 特質 感受情緒
那當我今天開始想要回去擁抱
這些東西的時候
其實我覺得最需要勇氣的
不是在於我要怎麼改變
我要怎麼調整
我要怎麼走下一步
而是我要怎麼看清楚
那件事情很可怕
然後我看清楚之後
我要選擇怎麼做
我要選擇讓他出來嗎
給大家看到嗎
還是不出來
但不出來我覺得又要花力氣了
我看清楚
就是因為別人有什麼
看三四三 看誰不是誰
你看三不是三
你已經看到了
結果現在你得藏起來
那更累
所以我在看你這本書的時候
我覺得這好像是你一貫寫作的習慣
就是你很真實
你會把你真實的感受
真實的經驗
然後甚至有的時候是比較刺的
或是比較直接的那個部分
直接出現
所以我就會很好奇
因為演員很需要夾我
連我做這個工作都需要夾我
大家對心理師的期待
就是有時候我看到有些人留言
我也是很想問問他今天過得好不好
但是可能考慮到身為心理師
他代表的意義
他對大家會造成的社會影響
以及你今天留了這個言之後
會不會有一些支持你的人
他也會跟著對對方有一些攻擊
然後反而造成更大的
就是其實是沒有必要的
那個情緒壓力的
最後我們都得選擇認下來
這樣之類的
但是我的意思是說
所有的夾我這件事情在目前工作者
甚至我們日常生活社會化的過程
都非常非常重要
也非常非常常會被訓練
你怎麼面對這件事
你怎麼有辦法讓你自己這麼真實
我覺得大家對你有期待
可是你也不要辜負
你自己對自己的期待
我會期待我自己在我安全的範圍
跟安全的空間裡
盡情的展現我的真實
但是如果我跟人互動的話
當然因為親疏遠近
所以我會選擇就是尊重的方式
例如說遇到想法不同的人
遇到比較憤怒的人
或是他今天可能心情很差
所以他想要把惡意散發在這裡
那你可以選擇
你要去承接這個惡意跟他吵起來
或是你就讓這個惡意被擺在這裡
但是你可以遠遠的去觀看他
觀察他
就有時候遇到一些我比較沒有辦法
當下承接的事情
我會把它當成一個角色去分析
就會想說
如果未來我演到這樣的角色
他的心理狀態是什麼
他的潛台詞是什麼
他剛發生了什麼事
他五年前發生了什麼事
然後思考以後
我覺得因為演員這個工作
你可以更去統理他人
他現在變成眼前這個樣子
他一定是累積而來的
那因為我不知道他前面發生了什麼事
所以我沒有辦法在現階段判斷他
但是我願意接受他
表達他的意見的情緒跟狀態
因為他是自由的
我也有自由不接這個球
好厲害喔
所以你在很現在的狀態裡面
你已經很可以在我們心裡學會說
別人的議題你會還給對方
而且你可以看得很清楚
那是別人的
你不會馬上跟著隨之其物
或是有反應
超強的耶
因為你剛剛講的那一個
把它當成角色分析
這跟我們心理師有時候在做的事情很像
但是我不知道是不是所有心理師都會這樣
但我以前曾經就是遇到
人際關係很困難的人際關係
我就把他當成是我
不能轉介的困難個案
然後心理就覺得好多了
他說困難個案的話
不能轉介啊
那我們就來想想怎麼辦好了
就心理就會覺得好多了
跟你的角色分析很像
就是有點像是
這個人怎麼會這樣
他為什麼會這樣處理
可是這樣的比較後設的方式
的確是非常棒的方法
就是他會幫助我們
比較可以用前而業工作
然後也比較能夠把議題還給對方
因為就會比較知道
為什麼他需要這麼做
而不是為什麼他對我這麼做
對
這差很多
在我這個在書寫的過程中
我也是因為長大了
回去看以前的事情
我就會發現
就是你以前很像很容易過度反省
就是別人對待你的模式
你會過度反省自己
是不是自己做了什麼
導致於別人這樣對待我
可是後來我覺得
你長大一點以後
你就看到當我
長到那個人的年紀的時候
我可能遇到生活中很多
不順遂的事情
我可能會習慣性的去找一個
不相干的人發洩
這就等於那是他的事情
他不是我的事情
可是以前我會把他連結在一起
所以長大以後
你有辦法把他斷開的時候
我覺得那也是一種療癒
就是長大以後
想明白這件事以後
我就可以比較把這件事情放下了
但是那需要經過時間
雖然你講得很輕
但實際上要做到這件事情
是非常困難的
所以你從什麼時候開始發現
其實有的時候
我們不小心會去承擔別人的議題
然後我們會把它變成
就像你說的自我反省
然後什麼時候
你開始發現
其實很多時候
你只是剛好在錯誤的時間
到了錯誤的地點
然後被遇到了
被剝擊了
對 然後你就被影響了
但實際上可能跟你
不一定有很大的關係
你是怎麼做到的檢視
你什麼時候開始
很有意識的去調整這個部分
我覺得你只要花時間
回到一個人的狀態
你就會知道這些事情
其實跟你沒有關係
因為我是從
人比較少的地方
來到人比較多的地方
我生長的環境
人很少
然後
大家都在自己的狀態裡
大自然的東西比較多
就是都是植物
好棒喔 在哪裡啊
就在山上
然後鄰居可能就是
也都在自己的家裡
然後種自己的花
然後有時候有交流
他們也不會
一定要跟你見到面
就例如說他家長了腳白筍
他就是會把他家收成腳白筍
多的就掛在你們上
但他也不一定會按電鈴去打擾你
那你家有多的玉米
你也就是直接去放在他家門口
但是大家其實是
各自在自己的宇宙裡的
跟著自然一起生活
那後來我從
人淹稀少的地方來到人群
擁擠的都市
你就會發現有非常多資訊跟
人際關係
那因為我不太熟悉
所以我有時候的確會有那種看不懂
或是因為你
根本就不知道別人在想什麼
所以產生了各種誤解
可是當你慢慢的在這個環境待久
你慢慢看得懂一點點東西以後
你再回到自身
你就發現其實脫離的那個環境
就是這個環境結束以後
這個場景結束以後
你回到人淹稀少的地方
或是你回到你個人
這一切其實都與你無關
好通透哦
所以就是體感上的與你無關
跟聲音上環境上的與你無關
你就會發現獨處真的是必要的
你才可以避免把別人的東西
帶到自己身上
然後讓自己很不舒服
但是其實那個根本就跟你沒有關係
哦
我覺得你講的
我超級就是有共鳴耶
我不知道現在在聽的
各位聽眾跟觀眾朋友
大家聽到這一段
感覺怎麼樣
就是我們常常講
獨處很重要
跟自己相處很重要
為什麼這件事情這麼重要
是因為
我們才知道
我們的世界重要的事情
到底是什麼
然後真的才有辦法可以選擇
我因為我也是屬於
日常生活獨處
時間需要非常非常長的人
然後我覺得獨處這件事情
他幫助我就是
度過很多以前
就是在人際上很糾結
自我懷疑
然後很多很不舒服的時刻
所以我剛才聽你分享
獨處這件事情的重要
還有你剛剛說山上大愛
皎白筍會放在你家門口
或掛一束花
哦我覺得
這真的好讚哦
我就覺得怎麼會有這麼尊重
大家界限的地方
連寒暄都省了
真的
就是直接把今年好的皎白筍
今年好的玉米互相交流
因為每個人種的東西不一樣
真的我給你的就是
我真實的好意
我們不用演
這件事情好棒哦
那你後來下山之後
就是仙女下山之後
就是羽衣被人家縮起來
只好下山的時候
就發現完蛋了
山下的人都要演
你是就直接來台北嗎
對啊
哦塞
一下子就大魔王
例如說附近有公園
我那時候
因為我找的地方
其實都會接近大自然
就是我下山以後
會找例如說附近有公園
那時候幾歲啊
我其實很晚才下山
我27塊28歲才下山
太棒了
所以公已經都練完了
就是在山上待了一瞬子以後才下山
然後我剛下山的時候
就是我弟弟還有我妹妹
就很緊張
他們就覺得說
你就在山上陪爸媽就好像不要下來
然後我就那個叛逆的心
就覺得說
為什麼你們都不讓我體驗
因為他們很早就有離開山上的經驗
他們有念別的地方的大學
然後我就說
你不會讓我永遠待在山上
我要去體驗一下山下的生活怎麼樣
然後我那時候其實給自己一年的時間
因為你如果有時間的話
你就會覺得說
那在這一年都是體驗
然後我本來想說我就下山一年
然後後來就接到了電視劇
比較長的我第一次接到
所以就是開始一直拍戲
然後就住在山上會比較不方便
甚至叫不到車
然後我爸就要一直接我
我就覺得還是住在山下比較方便
然後就一路住到現在
但是我覺得
因為我都是選有大自然附近的地方住
所以我還是有可以回到那種
比較自然的安靜的地方的感覺
但是人比較多之後真的
徹底的放鬆跟遠離這一切的那個體感
就比較薄弱
感覺你以前是住在山裡面森林裡面
你現在是住在一個
城市的盆栽造景裡面
雖然都是大自然的元素
可是密度差很多
就會還蠻需要時間再回大自然走走
就是你要調適嗎
因為活在這世界上
不可能永遠不跟人交流
只是你可以選擇
那個交流的頻率跟密度
是
如果聽起來就是
那個前面
你有一些在山上比較自在的
不用演很多
不用太社會化的部分
對你的幫助是很大的
感覺在你後面就是
必須下山面對大家的這一些
可是這個適應的過程
你有沒有遇到一些
你覺得比較困難跟內心
就是我以前學到的東西
跟我心的必須適應的東西
打架
最後你必須做選擇的狀況
我覺得人其實是
適應力很強的物種
我覺得像這地球上很多動物
他們的棲地被破壞以後
他們會面臨絕種
但我覺得人之所以到現在
人口爆炸或是我們人
我覺得是因為人適應力非常強
所以你把一個人丟到什麼樣的環境
會造就什麼樣的人的狀態
我覺得我是一個從我體感上很舒服的
人煙稀少的地方來到
有人群的地方
我還是
有辦法適應
因為我會調配
我會選擇
例如說
我休假的時候我就會去人少的地方
什麼是人少的地方呢
就是你離開監風時段出門
你在大家都沒有放假的時候
去某一些地方
那你感覺到的都還是人言息小的時候
所以我是盡量會避開人群的
這個調適讓我覺得也OK啊
我在這個地方
但是我想收到了
沒有人群的時刻
就像過年的台北突然變得很空曠
那這個東西就
沒有人口密度那麼高
你比較不會被影響
別的節奏
走在路上比較不會被擦身而過撞到
年假時候的台北是很舒服的
那那個舒服是什麼
是因為人少
你可以比較關照自己
不用關照任何其他人
所以我覺得我在日常生活中
也一直在尋找
跟大家
不同的生活節奏
讓我自己避開人群
然後才有力量回歸人群
所以才有辦法去
就是適應跟調配那個
有時候可能需要一些社會化適應的
那個部分
就一年可能給自己幾個扣打
是需要待在人群裡的
那我聽你這樣講
我就突然覺得
你剛剛說的那個內容很有趣
就是因為你書裡面也有講到
關於婚禮參加婚禮
因為妹妹的婚禮跟弟弟的婚禮
然後你本來有打算
就是不要去弟弟的婚禮
人太多了
對
然後剛剛我們閒聊的時候
你也跟我說
如果你沒去的話
你第一可能也就
明白我
對 正常的那樣釋放
然後你剛剛又講
你那時候要下山的時候
弟弟妹妹切切以為不可
你就在家裡等陪爸媽就好
我就很有趣
所以你看弟弟妹妹的關係
或你在家裡
因為很多老大從小就被訓練
又是最早社會化的
所以很多老大都是
說長女病
最近可能流行的書
或者是說很會適應
平常在家裡多麼阿爸是一回事
但出來外面就是人模人樣
然後都是別人家的小孩這樣
聽起來你好像比較不是這樣
所以我有點好奇
你跟你弟弟妹妹在家裡
展現的樣子是什麼
這個部分可以聊嗎
可以
我覺得我弟弟妹妹是
很多時候是看不下去
有可能是因為我小時候
身體比較不好
就是我是體弱多病的
所以可能弟弟妹妹
他們會去跟鄰居玩
然後我就會在家看書
所以他們往外跑的時候
他們接觸到這個世界的不同人
跟不同類型的社交
他們比較有很多經驗
那我的社交經驗就是跟書而已
當他們見到這麼多人以後
回頭看姐姐就覺得
姐姐好像
姐姐怎麼了
她心力可能會比我們弱
或她發展的這個部分
一定會比我們弱
他們就會自己生起一個
要照顧姐姐的心
他們比較早去接觸人
然後因為我身體很弱這件事情是
家裡都很能理解的
就是我是那種
只要一出門天氣稍微變天
我就會感冒
就是那種很容易生病
很常在看醫生
所以大家對我就沒有什麼期待
只期待我身體健康而已
好好活著
對 就是不要再感冒
不要再生病
不要在這裡痛那裡痛
然後不要再送急診室
大家就不會對我有長女的期待
什麼要做好榜樣或是什麼
姐姐只要身體健康
就已經是很棒的
因為她平常連這件事都做不到
然後當然長大的過程中
因為他們念離開山上的學校
交通很遠
他們要住校什麼的
他們都比我早經歷這一切
他們的興趣又比較多元
所以很多事情都是他們比我前面
那當然回頭看
姐姐還在自己的房間裡看書
就會覺得姐姐到底在幹嘛
我有點好奇
因為當你講說弟弟妹妹
他們有時候會很擔心你
或者是覺得說
你這樣真的可以嗎
姐姐這樣不行
你可以隨便舉個例嗎
就是什麼樣的
就是跟他人的互動
或者怎麼樣他們就覺得
就是姐我覺得你還是先不要
就是會有這種反應
你可以隨便舉一些例子嗎
就例如說像過馬路這件事
我們在山上是沒有板馬線嗎
就是都是山路
我弟弟和我妹妹都很會過馬路了
我也不知道為什麼
然後我可能下山的時候
我光是要過馬路
我就要在路邊站非常非常久
我要等都沒有車我才想要過
就是有時候會有一些沒有
沒有紅綠燈
但是就是那種路
他那個路很小
其實這很小條
甚至沒辦法畫板馬線
車量變少就可以過了
我就要等很久
就是確定都沒有車我才要過
就是我要覺得要跟山上的感覺
很像我才敢過
然後我妹就會很震驚
就說姐你在幹嘛
然後我說我在等沒有車
然後我妹就會覺得
現在就已經可以過了
所以我妹就會牽著我的手過馬路
就是這種看不下去
然後他們就會直接
幫我把事情做完
然後可是長到一個階段以後
就是當我發現他們
都有很多能力的時候
我也會覺得
那我也要給自己更多挑戰
然後他們就會說
姐你不要鬧
你做不到
然後我就會被激勵
所以我覺得其實是互相的
就是他們雖然比我快
可是當我想做這件事的時候
我想嘗試的時候
他們只要一阻止我
我就會覺得說
我要做給你們看這樣
就還是做得到
對啊
所以我覺得這個東西很有趣是
因為你的弟弟妹妹
好像常常會覺得
姐你不要鬧了
姐你讓我們看不下去
但其實他們很寵你耶
就是他們
很能接受你就是你原本的樣子
會接受我就是這樣啊
對
所以就是書裡面
我看到那個我真的覺得很害羞
因為你很討厭去婚禮
就忍太多了
忍太多人完全可以理解
而且都要那種
哎呀最近怎麼樣啊
過得不錯
阿姨看起來也很年輕
什麼時候要結婚
呵呵呵
然後什麼時候要生小孩
然後賺多少錢
因為我在看你寫說
就是你弟弟覺得
就是你剛剛講嘛
如果你沒有去的話
你弟弟可能也覺得還好
對啊
就是他們可以明白我為什麼
因為小時候我們沒有那麼多需要社交
或是需要社會化
而你越長大越需要
那你爸爸媽媽對於賀然發現
本來覺得我這個小孩
健健康康長大
但爸媽通常是這樣
希望你健康
但你真的健康
他就開始有新的願望
所以當你
不是這麼社會化
比較做你自己想要的事情的時候
你爸爸媽媽他們的反應是什麼
我覺得我爸還滿
滿棒的
他不是那種很多話的爸爸
但是他是能理解你的那種
所以
例如說我的個性就是這樣
他也不會特別對我有要求
就會覺得說
啊反正你的個性就這樣
你以後工作結束以後
你可能也會想要搬回山上
那就是也不會有其他人
所以你這樣就這樣
他不會硬要我要去改變我的模式
就反正會覺得
我終究會回到沒有人的地方的
所以我也不用去做這些努力
超讚的
對 就是我爸不會去逼我
然後我爸是那種會默默的
例如說我剛開始演戲的時候
都是他接送嘛
也是到有一天我突然覺得很不好意思
因為我們拍片有時候是凌晨
我覺得我爸幾歲了
我從幼稚園小學
國中高中
就他就一直接送我
然後我就會覺得說
我弟會騎車開車
然後我妹有男朋友接送
那就只有我一路被接到
我下山之前都是我爸接送
然後突然覺得
27、28歲還在給爸爸接送
好像覺得
雖然我沒有要跟一般人比較
可是我覺得27、28歲還在給爸爸接送
好像不應該
我覺得我爸也應該要休息了
還有自己的事件
對 他要有自己的事件
不要一直在接送女兒
然後我就搬到山下
就比較叫車或是公車捷運
就比較方便
就不用從山上接送
所以我覺得我爸是
他不會要求我改變
他就是我要做什麼
他就是都會支持
就是連拍戲什麼
他就是問我隔天要幾點拍
他就是準備好就載我這樣
愛我媽媽的話
我媽媽就是
我覺得我媽是一個
我媽真的很酷
大部分的媽媽在小孩長大以後
可能會失去重心
就是可能會空巢期
覺得小孩長大了什麼什麼的
我覺得我媽他是
一個逆生長的人
就是我小時候會覺得
他很像一個成人
很像一個媽媽
可是當我長大以後
我就會發現
我媽以前一定扮演得很辛苦
他要假裝自己是一個媽媽
自己是一個大人
我媽其實是非常少女的人
很多人會覺得
媽媽會偏心自己的那一個小孩
我們家的小孩沒有這個困擾
因為我媽媽最愛的是他自己
他狀態我覺得其實非常好
所以有時候我長大以後
我其實會叫他洪小姐
我覺得他就是一個
照顧自己的
他就是一個越來越做自己的人
然後他的做自己是
你不會去想說
哇 他以前怎麼有辦法
讓我覺得他是個媽媽
因為我長大以後發現
其實他也很多事情
他也不會也不懂
但他就是從做中學
然後他現在小孩都長大以後
他就過他自己的
他甚至比我們還忙碌
他有自己的興趣
自己的交友圈
然後我們一天都在安排自己的生活
他不是一定要把重心
放在小孩身上的媽媽
他過得非常的忙碌
我聽你在講的時候
我突然有一個很深的感覺
就是
因為有時候我們在見到人的時候
在聽每個人在說話的時候
我們會感覺他在
現在在這個狀態自不自在
說話教不教略
會不會有一些需求
這些東西其實隱為的會感受得到
然後我說我看你的書的
很深的感受是覺得你很真實
那個真實其實很不容易
因為有的時候
我們在做出一個作品的時候
我們會努力
還是會忍不住想要展現
某方面希望別人看到自己
然後我在跟你對話的時候
我會很深的感覺到
你不焦慮
但真的
講這句話好像很簡單
他可能不是很能理解
我講不焦慮是什麼意思
就是我覺得你很自在的在跟我聊
很多不管是你自己很私人的
或是你的信念
或是什麼事情
並沒有一定要是某個樣子
而是你就是很像就是
我們現在在那個
就是你家的房間
你再跟我分享
我在想我如果談比較大的信念議題
大概如果我平常跟你聊天
你大概就是這個樣子
對 但是
我就在想是什麼可以讓你這麼安在
然後你剛剛在講爸爸媽媽那個部分
我就覺得
那我懂了
就是譬如說我自我在小時候比較特別
比較沒有那麼社會化的孩子
或多或少都會面對到需要跟這個社會
搏鬥的過程
掙扎的過程
然後我一直在想
你的穩定跟自在是怎麼生成的
後來聽到就是
你的爸爸媽媽
讓你可以不用假裝
不用壓抑
也不用改變
然後我覺得可以保有一個
現在能夠接納自己的每一個狀態的狀況
是年輕的時候在小的時候
有經驗到
這樣的事情才做得到的
所以我覺得就是好棒
我不知道怎麼形容
這件事我在旁邊看我就覺得好棒
因為就包含我自己
我自己在某些時候表現某些東西的時候
我一樣會有我的焦慮在
因為我在人際上
曾經有過比較大的
比較沒有那麼舒服的人際經驗
其實我的媽媽可能是比較包容我的
但是我在人際上是有一些創傷經驗在的
所以在某些展現的樣子
或是某些描述跟某些言語表達中
我仍然會有我的焦慮在
可是很明顯我可以在你身上
完全秀不到那個味道
因為身為焦慮人是很容易
穩得到人家身上的焦慮
但我有時候會覺得我是不是太舒理了
就是有很舒服
我實在是太舒服了
我想說我有時候也會再看一下
大家在某一種緊密的關係中
我追求的是疏離嗎
因為也許就像你剛剛說的
我家裡的每一個人都有各自的狀態
我覺得我們家很像是
我們活在同一個家裡
但好像每一個人都在不同的環境下成長
每一個人都是一個小宇宙
然後這個球
每個人有自己的領域跟自己的
那會遇到
但是然後有繞出去
會一起吃飯
但是每個人有自己的狀態
然後有熟悉感
可是我覺得我們又不是那種
很緊密到要影響對方的
因為我們每一個人
我們家的每一個人都無法影響對方
就是每個人都有自己的宇宙自己的疏離
說不定那一個梳理感跟台灣社會
在親密關係
貓含家人也是一種親密關係的呈現
有很大的關聯性
因為台灣的習慣的傳統的親密關係
就是要交換
你要是要愛我
我要是要愛你
我們都要交換出我們自己
自我一部分的獨立性
跟獨立思考的能力
因為我要對你認同
你也要對我認同
所以我要的不是支持
我要的是認同
所以不只是父母是這樣小孩也是這樣
父母如果不認同我的夢想
不是支持
我先不講支持不支持
你認不認同這件事情
就會對我的人生造成很大的傷害
可能就會讓我覺得
你一輩子都不肯定我
我說的不是這個不好
我說的是這是我們文化上
一個很習慣的交換
來獲得親密感的一個部分
我之前因為你剛剛在講那個疏離
是不是
等一下我們今天明明是很輕鬆的唸書
為什麼我們好像講得很像很哲學
大家忍耐好不好
因為我們今天找俞涵來
就是長這樣
所以大家忍耐
就是因為我
我想到我之前讀那個佛洛姆
有講到逃避自由
他那一本書就有講到說
很多人
天生顯然不是只有台灣
在國外可能也是這樣
在獲得想要親密感這個人士
就是必須要交付出部分的自己
要用自我來當成獻祭的
那個祭品來換的
就是用忠誠
對這個關係的忠誠
才能得到親密
當然佛洛姆原文不是這樣講
我講得比較誇張一點
可是他說真正的親密
其實是可以用
我們各自的確是獨立的
然後也許你會不認同
或不能理解我的什麼
我願意讓你知道
我願意告訴你分享我脆弱的部分
我真實的感受
你不一定可以認同我
可是我們的親密感的建立是藉由分享
那個真正的自己而建立的
而不是賣掉
真實的自己放棄
真實的自己建立的
他說這個才是真正的親密
才不會讓我們在這關係中
感覺到空虛
才不會讓我在關係中
覺得我一定要演什麼角色
你才會愛我
當然他原文不是講成這樣
但是意思差不多是這樣
然後我覺得這一段
我覺得好美喔
所以你剛剛在講
你們家人的那個關係
就讓我想到這段
而日常生活我其實很少遇到
這樣子的關係在台灣社會
的確不容易
可能我們家人都各自做自己吧
沒有在管對方
我覺得很有趣
你剛剛聽我這樣講
你感覺怎麼樣
我沒有這樣想過
但我覺得這個詮釋
我覺得很美耶
很讚喔
很美
想不想去看佛洛姆
對 很棒耶
大家可以
我會想要去搜尋這個
我們可以把那個書
逃避自由 佛洛姆
很好看
雖然說如果你覺得
不習慣看那個字很多的
不然就是俞涵你趕快看
看完之後你把你的心得
你趕快寫出來跟他分享
就知道了很多書單
我覺得這個很棒
因為沒有這樣子
觀察過這件事情
我只有就我自己的經驗
跟身邊的人
跟家人的經驗
去做學習跟對照
但是我覺得無論你怎麼樣對照
還是只能長成你
你家住是自然會長成那樣
可能每個人的個性使然
所以我覺得剛剛聽你講這個
這個部分我覺得很有趣
然後因為你的書裡面
其實有非常多議題
但我們時間關係
真的想鼓勵大家去買書
真的很好看
所以很鼓勵大家看的時候
如果你是女性
或者是你想瞭解女性的生活
我真心覺得在看這本書裡面的
很多狀態都是我們小時候
會遇到的
學會不要跟一些
侵略性很強的人四目交接
這樣子就不會被注意到
小時候大家都在訓練自己這件事
現在到這個年紀
因為已經不獲之年
學會的就是反而要四目交接
你看看什麼看
瞪回去
然後對方就會默默的把眼神
因為夠老
然後看起來夠兇
眼眨就會飄走這樣
那小時候我們真的都是訓練自己
不要被看見
然後最好被忽略
把自己藏起來
這幾乎是很多女性的
一個很習慣保護自己的方式
所以我接下來想跟你討論的
另外一個部分
雖然我們今天有講說
你的書裡面想講的是
包含擁抱自己的陰影
然後包含孤獨
包含跟世界和解
可是我看到你的書裡面
我有看到一個很重要的東西
而我發現這個東西有很多人沒有
那就是怎麼樣保護自己
我在看你特別是你前面
在講你的經驗
就是有遇到一些包含
侵犯身體界限
或者是
他可能還沒到這個程度
但是他也許就是
騷擾你
但是
就是我看到這有點氣
我看到那個輔導師
我心裡想說
幸好你沒有因此對心理諮商的聲音
沒有
我覺得就是
在這邊我想要
就特別分享這個經驗
就是我覺得
心理諮商這件事情
是現在越來越
大家有在做的事情
那當然心理諮商
就像你日常生活中
會遇到頻率隊的人
或是有些人跟你頻率
就是比較遠
那心理諮商是也是一樣的
所以你在
去心理諮商的時候
如果你覺得你跟這個心理諮商師
沒有辦法在這個空間裡面
很舒服
那可以換
真的
對
所以不要因為一次的諮商
或是一次的輔導經驗不好
你就對這件事情
從此劃上了句號
就是不要為了一件事情
去放棄其他
然後我其實也是滿推薦大家
心理諮商的
就是我覺得這件事情是
我長大以後
我覺得
他對我來說是一個很棒的反思
就是很多你就是
完全忽略掉的細節
其實有可能是
你現在長成這樣
跟你為什麼會有這些慣性的原因
那我覺得我去心理諮商是
我對我自己有興趣
我想要知道更多
然後透過別人跟我對談
我會回去一直思考這些事情
我覺得心理諮商對我來說是一件
很有趣的
心理的健身
就是我身體的肌肉
對
就像我去爬山
或是我去做那些器材
我覺得
心理也需要這個部分
那他當然一開始會不太舒服
就像你在弄那些器材的時候
你就會覺得天啊
我要
我的肌肉要爆掉
好酸哦
可是那是你不習慣
你習慣以後你會更有機會去看見自己
內心的東西
很好玩
我完全同意
因為我自己也會常跟大家講說
把心理諮商當成是一場重訓
所以有很多人就會覺得說
那我如果今天就是
面對情緒很大
我遇到一些事情我反應就會很大
可是老師你叫我去
開始去慢慢覺察自己在
面對這件事情的時候
感受是什麼
在想什麼
為什麼會做這個決定
為什麼會做出這個行動
我覺得好難哦
我沒有辦法
我停不下來
我就是會爆炸
怎麼辦
然後還有些人就會說
老師如果我一直都只是在想
我自己的感受
我會不會變成自我感覺非常良好的人
我會不會從此不會自行
只會只考慮自己
那個問法就跟我在第一天重訓的時候
跟教練說
教練我以後會不會成為一個肌肉人
我會不會以後變成金剛巴比
然後在這個時候我的體脂肪
還是34%的時候
我的教練就會說
你現在要不要聽聽你在說什麼
就是想太遠了
他只是一個開始
但是他沒有每個人都會長那樣
是
所以我覺得你剛剛在分享
這個就是心理諮商這個部分
我非常非常認同你的想法
然後回到心理諮商
他其實也是一個在訓練我們
可以保護自己的肌肉
可是我發現有很多人
在從小的成長環境中
其實沒有學會保護自己
因為我那時候看到保護自己
很深的感覺就是你寫
那個就是包含有一些被別人騷擾
然後的一些經驗
我想問就是對你來說
你覺得你是怎麼樣慢慢長出
這個保護自己的能力
或者是說你可以跟我們分享一下
就是你在書裡面講的
那一個很簡單講一下那個例子
因為那個例子還包含有權威的
兩種權威不同的處理方式
對你的影響
我覺得就是
小時候大家可能
還小的時候
有一些人可能就會覺得說
看你不懂
或看你還涉世未深
他就是
他自己的慾望比較濃烈
他完全不管你在想什麼
例如說他覺得
我就想跟你當朋友
但他用的方式是很不自然的
或是那種很有侵略性的
然後所以他可能會想辦法
去要到你的資訊啊
然後就一直用一種很執著
就是很多影像故事裡面
會把他演得很專情
或是他一直跟著你回家
或是什麼的
但這些東西
他其實對另外一個人來說
是一種壓迫
那因為我
我其實不太喜歡有人
違反我意願的
去靠近
或是接近
或是他有意圖
我可以感覺到
隱約他的意圖
有別的東西的時候
我是用動物的感覺
就是有一種
你好像變成了獵物的感覺
就是他
就是看你在那邊
他就是鎖定你了
他只要一有那個東西
我本人的動物直覺跟本人
我就會覺得怪怪的
可是我說不上來
那個不是語言
那個也不是他真的靠近你了
那是一種意念
但是我是願意相信我的感覺的
我覺得這件事怪怪的
雖然他什麼都沒有發生
雖然完全他都還沒有靠近我
我覺得怪怪的
當我覺得這個怪怪的
慢慢被驗證的時候
例如說有人就會說
他在打聽你在哪裡打工
他想要跟你做朋友
就開始有人放出這種
我覺得這個怪怪的對象
他在想要靠近我的時候
我的那個
雷達
逃跑的那個東西
就會立刻豎起來
我就會想說
我要怎麼樣避開這個鎖定
我要離開這個現場
不要讓他找到我
那個時候因為還小
所以我的處理方式是
逃跑
對
然後但是那時候我打工的地方的人
他知道
他的工讀生
好像要被騷擾了
他立刻跑過去就是
警告對方說
不要騷擾我們出師的工讀生
然後我在那一刻突然就看到
呃
兩種
處理方式
一個是
他
還沒有在發生任何事的時候
他對你已經投射了各種想像
想辦法要靠近你
一個是
他在
你還沒有做出任何
舉動之前
他就先立刻阻止了這件事的發生
然後我在那一刻我就覺得
如果我要長成一個成熟的大人
我覺得要長成那個
可以在看到事情有一點點不對勁的時候
我就直接喊停的人
我不要去等之後發生了以後
在那邊告訴自己說
你看吧我就說那個人怪怪的
我幹嘛等到之後發生
我如果我的第六感就覺得說這個人
他就是讓我覺得不舒服有點怪怪的
如果在那一刻我已經有長出第六感
我就要相信自己的第六感
但當然你不是每次都有第六感
可是
有任何這樣的感覺的時候
就是先避開危險
無論那個危險是
他只是很想要跟你做朋友
他只是很熱心
那可是我不喜歡啊
我為什麼要幫他找理由
沒錯
我覺得這個不是說要保護自己
而是我尊重了我自己
不喜歡這些事情
那我就可以不接受別人的大善
我也可以不接受別人的好意
因為你的好意對我來說
讓我有負擔
然後
我就算會被說很不是會話
或是有人只是
想要跟你當朋友你幹嘛跑走
我就算被指責
我也會覺得OK
這是我的選擇
我覺得俞涵
你剛剛把保護自己這件事情
直接帶到了另外一個
更重要的概念
那就是我在做的
不只是保護自己這種事情
我做的其實是在尊重意願
可是有很多人不敢保護自己
就是因為沒有辦法尊重自己的意願
因為我印象很深刻
你那個書裡面就講到
你處室的那一個
leader他是用
就是你不要叫那個騷擾你的人
你不要來騷擾我們
處室的工讀生
他很清楚他的信念就是
我不管你的理由是什麼
總之我的信念就是
你不能來騷擾我們這邊
涉世未生的學生
這是不對的
他很重視他的信念
然後他也很尊重你的意願
因為你看起來就沒有想很想要
跟對方有什麼互動的樣子
可是另外也有另外一個權位
我記得裡面就是講到
那個輔導室的部分
他的問法就是說
為什麼你要拒絕一個男生
想要跟你當朋友
還是想要跟你
又對你有好意的那個
我看了我心裡想說
還好你後來還是願意
就是覺得心理諮商是個好東西
我心裡想說 這是問什麼東西！
但是這個東西
這個問法其實是非常標準
有很多女生不敢保護自己的原因
那就是對方會讓你覺得
如果這些人給的東西是好東西
不管是不是你要的東西
你都要硬著頭皮堅持下去
如果你拒絕的話
你就是打擾了皇城內的和氣
你為什麼要造成大家的麻煩
你為什麼要把事情看得那麼嚴重
所以你不能保護你自己
你不能尊重你自己的意願
因為你要考慮的是其他人的感受
我每次看到這個時候
我真的是整個都會
我就長大以後我就會想說
每個人的立場不一樣
那例如說我待的處室的長官
他是覺得說
人家就是來工作
沒有想要交朋友
你們這樣子一直打聽人家的個資
然後要過來交朋友
他就覺得很困擾啊
那可能輔導師是帶著一種
就是他理解了A也理解了B
所以他會把問題丟給你說
你為什麼這麼怕別人的靠近
或是好像把問題都丟給你
好像是你的問題
可是我覺得有一些問題
他不是好問題
你可以不要接受這個問題啊
有些問題他是已經挖了一個坑
讓你硬要去填那個答案
沒錯
可是問題是這世界上
又不是只有這個問題
是的
那時候我得到的問題是說
你還不要去思考一下
為什麼你這麼怕男生
然後我就會回想
我沒有怕男生
我只是怕不禮貌的男生
我也沒有怕男生
我只是怕侵略性很強的男生
所以這個問題他不成立
那這個問題他不是我的問題
所以當輔導師問我說
要不要接受諮商來討論
為什麼我這麼怕男生這個問題的時候
我就會覺得這個問題
他不是我的問題
他是你預判
他是你預設的問題
然後他也不是我的問題
所以我不要接這個球
所以我才說你很厲害的一個地方
就是你個人的信念非常清楚
你很知道你遭遇了什麼
然後你也很尊重你個人的信念
這讓你會面對這種權威
他硬要塞東西到你嘴巴裡的時候
你會不吃
你會不收
就是我非常非常同意就是
當他知道兩邊的說法
可是他選擇的問題是這個
這代表他並沒有真的理解兩邊的說法
他只是選擇了他個人信念的問題
他個人的信念就是
他認為這件事情需要處理的是
你怕男生
而不是當遭遇到這樣
就是比較有侵略性的行動的時候
我們面對的時候
我們的感受
還有我們的困擾是什麼
的時候你就會瞭解到這個個人的信念
的確我覺得做心理相關工作
的確是這樣
就是個人的信念很容易會影響
你工作的狀況
就是很明顯
所以我覺得我剛剛在聽你講的時候
我覺得這是一個非常棒的例子跟經驗
就是談到這裡
我覺得我不知道怎麼跟大家分享
就是我在跟俞涵對談的時候
我非常非常被你的那個堅定給吸引
雖然俞涵看起來是一個
好像很溫柔的人
但我相信今天聽這一段
就是我跟他對談的人
有很多人對俞涵一點都不陌生
所以可能已經很熟悉
俞涵的堅定
可是我覺得我就正在對面的時候
我在看你在說明一些
你自己在當下怎麼做決定
怎麼做判斷
怎麼做選擇的好幾段
我都可以感覺到你的那個堅定
就是你非常清楚
你為什麼會這麼想
你為什麼會這麼做
對你來說成為你這個人
你要做些什麼
你非常非常清楚
我覺得這個東西真的很吸引我
然後講句實話
就是書裡面也有非常多
這樣的東西
但我不得不說看到本人
還是比書還是吸引
但是因為你們沒辦法看到本人
所以請買書好嗎
就是我覺得我沒有辦法騙大家說
就是我看書的時候
我真的很被吸引
但是一個人活生生在我面前
直接把那個堅定展現給我看
我覺得是真的是很觸動我
那還是有更小的時候
更不懂事的時候有吃過虧嗎
可是我爸就是那種
會用很老的那種俗諺
在跟我解釋事情的人
我小時候跟我爸講
就是我可能吃虧的事情
我爸就會用很老實的聲音
跟我說吃虧就是佔便宜
你一定會學到什麼事情
那所以我覺得我的這個種子
放在那邊我就會覺得說
好既然我現在吃虧了
我就是因為小時候不懂事
所以被欺負了
那我的確下次再發生類似的事情的時候
我要從原本的這個吃虧
學到一點什麼
因為我已經有經驗
所以我會對自己有一個
就算只進步0.1或0.2
我的經驗值都不可以比
完全沒有經驗過這種吃虧的事情
還要弱
我會努力的讓自己進步
但是原本吃虧的事情
例如說是別人騷擾你
或是別人讓你覺得不舒服
在長大以後
我會重新去看這件事情
不會在像以前小時候那樣
覺得很委屈而已
我會從委屈中長出另外一個
東西叫做做這些事情的人不是我
我只是剛好被剝奪了
所以這些事情
我不應該覺得
好像我做錯了什麼
所以我會去想
你們現在應該覺得很愧疚吧
當這些人看得懂
你做的是以後
你應該要很愧疚的
就算你不會愧疚
你總有一天你會明白
你真的做了很不OK的事情
你這輩子
有機會道歉的話
一定要好好道歉
如果你沒有道歉
我覺得這些東西
他都會反撲到你身上的
因為我覺得這是能量的問題
所以其實我覺得
你剛剛在講的那個東西
我越來越清楚
在你身上感受到那個
很吸引我的「堅定」是什麼
就是你真的很站在你自己這一邊
我覺得你真的是你自己的那個好夥伴
我覺得這是超棒的
我不要替加害者著想
我覺得就是
你不小心被撞了受傷了
你傷口在痛
你還要去想
為什麼他剛剛撞我
為什麼他會今天忘了踩
煞車直接撞過來
我不要去為他找理由
他要道歉
沒錯
我不要為他找理由
所以先不說遠不原諒
我覺得這些人
我先不要幫他找台階
他要先面對自己的錯誤
是
對 然後我覺得也是因為這樣
如果我小時候
曾經犯過什麼錯誤
我曾經因為不成熟
而不小心傷害別人
有機會如果我真的有遇到
意識到自己的錯誤
我也會希望我自己有能力
或是有那個緣分去跟那個人道歉
我覺得這世界上是要學會道歉的
不可以忽略自己的
因為無知犯的錯
無知犯的錯他也是錯啊
所以我覺得要學會道歉
也要接受道歉
然後
原不原諒是看自己當下的智慧
但是不用去幫加害者找理由
是
所以我們今天最後啊
聽到俞涵講的這個部分
我覺得是一個很有勇氣的一個展現
就是我可以站在我自己這一邊
然後呢
我也有勇氣可以去承擔
也許我曾經做錯的事情
但是我也有勇氣可以選擇
面對當我被別人傷害的時候
我要走哪一條路
而這件事情是我的決定
我不用擔心或在意別人怎麼想
而是這一切都是我自己的決定
就是要站在自己這邊幫自己加油
因為活到最後
跟你自己待最久的
絕對不會是你的家人朋友
而是你自己
因為你不知道你身邊的人
什麼時候會登出
沒錯
然後你也不知道你自己什麼時候會登出
可是大部分的時候
其實你都跟你自己待在一起
所以不要把重心放在別人身上
是
所以當有時候我們會很在乎
誰有沒有背叛我們的時候
我們要先看看
我們自己有沒有背叛自己
就是應該站在自己這邊的時候
扯自己後腿
這真的是一件很危險的事情
而我想如果你想要對你自己
有更多的看見
能夠看見更多自己的脆弱
瞭解
俞涵是怎麼樣可以長出
這麼堅定的自己
怎麼站在自己這邊
歡迎大家
除了這一本新書
《刺蝟抱月亮》
之前俞涵也出了一系列散文
請大家多多支持
非常推薦給大家
感謝俞涵今天來我們的節目
我好像做了一場
實際的心理諮商
怎麼這麼說呢
我今天也沒做什麼
我覺得很療癒
我知道了
新的書單
我覺得很開心
我們下次再來討論
我覺得很棒
太棒了
謝謝俞涵
也謝謝大家～
陪伴我們度過這一個小時
那麼
周慕姿放心說
我們下次見囉
Bye Bye